all right guys bang-bang I've got Adam
here with me I'm super excited to have
this conversation he probably knows more
about more things than the most you I've
had on the podcast so thanks so much for
for doing this oh and uh bang bang to
your back that's awesome let's get into
your background maybe give us an
overview of kind of how we get to you
today running a family office and
building companies so people understand
your perspective well and let me clarify
I don't run a family office I want my
own family office which and there's
quite a difference between the two I
have all my own capacity I do lease
other people's capacity other family
office capacity and I am a part of the
syndicate because there is benefits to
having our own kind of Angeles operation
as well as back office as well as
collaborating on certain things which is
great family offices these days are a
little bit different than they used to
be because they've had taken a lot of
outside money so that kind of constrains
them and more philosophically it'll kind
of give a deviation to what if one
person wants to do with their body it's
now you have to kind of Beach a
consensus and making money is a it's not
a democracy it's a dictatorship so I'll
give you a little bit of my own
background and if I appreciate you
saying that I might have a more kind of
robust system of view and background
information than a lot of your guests
and now I feel kind of challenged by
that because I feel like that up I feel
like Kasparov or now Magnus well I just
want to have like 30 chess games going
on at once and then play them kind of
all at the same time and then you know
when I think that's awesome I want to do
that that's like a real mental challenge
I want
do that now I'll take 30 of your guys
will go from subject to subject and I've
listened to a lot of audience so let me
go back or we don't give you my own
history
and I know we were discussing a little
bit of this in advance so yeah well
that's interesting it might be our
delivery um
so which is late by the way which is
actually kind of agony so I came out of
wall street and let me actually start
even before that I knew from the time I
was probably five that I wanted to work
in finance I knew that I wanted to be
successful and then uh as the years go
by actually I didn't know that I wanted
to be in fine I knew that I wanted I had
a picture of myself and it just needed
to get more crystallized so I had kind
of like this crystal ball but it was
kind of very blurry and kind of like I
as a kid it was already kind of in its
most disturbed I've one of those snow
crystal than it was as a kid it was in
its most kind of disturbed state where
you can just kind of steal it you know
just enough of the Christmas tree
maybe you can see the green of it now
was it and then as the years went on I
think by tomorrow 12 or 13 I uh I had it
pretty figured out I mean to the tee I
had it figured out I knew I want to work
appointment to that I was very intrigued
by it not because of my own intellectual
pursuits because they really weren't
financed but it was kind of a means to
an end and I knew I had CERN that I've
been blessed with certain things that I
needed to kind of turn into a more
durable currency even as a kid so I
spent you know it kept on getting
clearer and clearer and I wasn't
particularly I went to law in seminary I
went to PS 41 I went to CNN so I went to
some great schools my family
very long middle-class public schools
are very affordable and I had the whole
stack of books that's okay so everywhere
I went I think the largest stock was
probably and so I I when I was in school
I already knew what I wanted to do but
in school you can't really put your
fifth grade you can't really pick and
choose I knew I loved history on my
history was just too brief what was
occurring so I spent a lot of time in
the library I couldn't care about math
in the way it was being presented which
was arithmetic always something you can
just pick up on their own you know
honestly as long as they have that kind
of con stuff that that desire there's a
reason for that to attitude into they'll
they can figure it out really quickly
for themselves the same is true with
geometry but I didn't see any reason for
calculus and I didn't see any reason for
a lot of the places where I was spending
my time I was very intrigued by language
so I did manage the language so I
finished school as much as I could into
there now you know more than colonists
as everybody else does I ate a college
because I felt that I already knew what
I wanted to do and this just wasn't what
I wanted to do and I was interacting
with kids that definitely didn't know
what they wanted to do and it was a
distraction because I've never you know
I know it's just not my thing
and I thought that they were interfering
even though they were all my friends
so I felt that was biting my tongue to
go to Wall Street and then when I was
about 19 years old I I knew that I was
ready I was working in a retail job at
that time I've been working a record
actually was working at the gap
I went from job to job at that time
because I wasn't particularly interested
but they knew I needed to buy my time so
I I wound up back then boasting is much
more
kind of the the big people the the Jamie
diamonds everybody else were much more
accessible I mean you could just give
them a pole I would look Oh
and that is what I did I'm a very firm
believer it kind of optimizes the path
from A to Z so that's what I did and I
fold fold my way into gold sacks and I
cold hold my way into a flop
I controlled my way into several firms
many of which didn't have interested
which respond they wasn't particularly
insulted by that and everybody was very
calling telling why they didn't have
pictures to me and a lot of the reason
that they didn't have interest in me was
they wanted somebody that could hit the
ground running and just get get revenue
positive and I certainly couldn't do
that where they wanted somebody to throw
money strong which was more than just a
broker but even within that they wanted
a smaller I wasn't interested in it so I
wound up meeting with or like round up
really having a great relationship with
two analysts in different forms one of
them is a golden sentence and he was
essentially the analyst that discovered
Microsoft Lotus and the other one
essentially discovered Mike for long I
went to semiconductor side of it I did
very well I did very well by accident
you know he loved me and they love me
and they embraced me and I did
incredibly long I was just very lucky to
write this that another way time and I
had the right gift he my men who were
there quit and he left me that's when
the largest position in micron on Wall
Street so I had to become smart very
quickly and that required learning but a
short sleeve is and participating in one
and I became part of the short Buster's
Club what we did and we squeeze other
short such as can see
the Rangers I I then left that left that
firm for a wanderlust and I was offered
a lot of money to go to a firehouse but
and I went there I had the largest
position and my phone vo saw a whole
bunch of other things which put a lot of
risk on their plate so I started my own
shop I did I did an investment bank they
did stab wall mostly with in
semiconductors an act an accusation one
of them was on the acquisition of Zio's
which became my clone electronics and
which became my phone and and that
itself was just amazing and I I started
a research arm and two years later I
knew I was going to sell two years later
I sold it and at that time I thought I
was I was just back then there was
actually a lot of money and that was
already one of the big producers on Wall
Street so I didn't want to go back I
know what pattern recognition is and I I
try and avoid it that can be a very bad
thing so long I um I took two years off
or like when I traveled all over the
place and when I came back Silicon Alley
was just beginning which is in Manhattan
was just beginning in about calm and
tripod friendly look at that talk so far
there's my Opstal ventures and it was
just a different venture capital world
there was different companies they
called it an internet 1.0 which was I
knew was ridiculous at the time but
nevertheless I swore off I invested in
one of those and many of them got
acquired you know some of them were just
interesting to observe such as pseudo
programs which did and I watched
broadcast comm initially and it becomes
successful and as those positions were
sold off
I need monitoring that again either
I had dawn kind of the investment meet
within that and now I'm kind of though
when I would think of as a real estate
speculator idea known by funding a lot
of those companies out of my own pocket
and not even bothering going through a
VC give it a fake I just put on every
kind of table that was Oh including
something losers called so after I
cashed those positions and after sudo
programs have basically been in its
death throes and Josh had gone you know
off the wall I I saw what one of the
gapping needs within that industry was
which is these companies back then you
might be a little bit while growing from
two employees or ten employees to 400
and this would happen so quickly that
they didn't build up the internal
capacity the human resources capacity
which expose them to a lot of ways so
one of the things that was happening is
these companies were being acquired or
considering even being the bar taking VC
dollars was the they needed to plan
holes in their financial box which
usually and a little bit along other
problems as well and they also had a lot
of exposure in lawsuits everybody on
their way out was suing for sexual
harassment and other things and
obviously the cases didn't have merit
but usually it's it's done to increase
the severance package or when a company
is looking to obtain venture capital
particularly back then it was done as a
mechanism of almost extortion that
they're gonna obstruct him the venture
capital round with any claims so they
went in they would embellish something
there was a lady probably involved and
the companies were making him so very
vulnerable to that because they were
doing horrible things so that's it I I
don't want to Stein guilt to one party
any diminution for the other so long I
decided to invest in I made an
investment in the company called at that
time it didn't staff and it was a small
investment was fifty thousand mile or so
around thing know is well that was when
I still had my own piece of chalk and
and maybe 1995 it was a $50,000
investment that was introduced to me for
a Methodist minister of all things
I'm not Methodist the news it was the
Texas environment at that time is really
becoming very entrepreneurial which was
really remarkable watch I think we're
seeing a resurgence coming down so
admitted staff did really well I think
it's worth I haven't looked you don't
pay attention to these things anymore
photo last time I saw a few years ago
was to Billy and the stock is don't know
more than double then and we still have
a very large position there one time I
own five percent of the company
and when they owned five percent of the
company you need to have I went over he
become sales over there which was
incredible really but I didn't really
need the money and I was just extremely
successful but I also on five percent
equipment and when you're in that
position you can either be an investor
or you can be employed can't really
people and even though they found it was
a a good friend of mine in the middle it
compromised our relationship to the
point it still hasn't performers you
can't be both and the stock because I do
so much about you it's easy in 2001
during the internet one of those
thoughts the Stockland from $20 to $2
and this is a New York Stock Exchange
listed company there was almost a Morgan
so that's really unheard of and there
was a lot of things that drove that and
a lot of those things that drove over
fall and in 2006 the stock was not
trading at 60 so I did you know I think
well you're gonna knock on something but
I don't have what available I have my
chair in a weighing spirit of
appreciation is whatever I not gone so
you know I I cashed out someone it sorry
cash out of that large of a physician
and I became investors in the private
equity far administer was the early
is PL professional organization that is
they entreated that mocked modern
industry they did all the lobbying
things literally just weed what's now
kind of accepted you want with a
detective this we do with the health so
they created anything with a premium and
still are low tier AAA flossed player a
private equity firm asked me to put in a
freely acknowledge or then they said
that we want to build our own here they
were clients of mine actually a unit
staff which is now called its parity
they are never clients of mine and I
love them they say a dog we want to do
the same thing so we acquired a state we
bought out the position from Bessemer
which was having big cash problems at
the time it's a green venture capital
firm no no it was just you know a
perfect storm that hit them and
sometimes when the venture capital foam
is too successful it also means you have
to give people's money back they just
want to cash out and that can cause it's
only problems this is crazy but it is
what it is a lot of big investors have
now myself included sometimes we want to
take New Zealand so we bought our
position and company will join it then
we bought another position to publicly
traded company there was gold jeopardy
which was trading around two dollars a
share
back come but he had a 75 which is a PE
of professional education that company
finally a seventy five million dollars
cash in the bank or that was due to it
because of all we made from their work
up the business and the acquisition cost
us a hundred million dollars so it was
it was good we two companies were
blending the private equity firm took a
lot of ownership of the whole thing
beyond just that but in this case it was
general one tea party and one of the
remarkable things about general on to
produce Sequoia worm still
take the plate and NEA which is the same
it's got some does you than everybody
and is that general Atlantic Sequoia NEA
and me our industries are the most
durable currency so they are the
American dollar
they're the most durable currency if
general antics going to commit two
hundred million dollars are also going
to commit to billions so that they
committed to very knowledgeable we made
a lot of acquisitions TriNet now is
called a dwarf everybody I had a very
large position in their very large and
the company went public in 2012 and in
2012 another one way early investment
public which was called which is called
update which is now kind of a dorm also
and it was founded by the guys really
have done PeopleSoft before that people
thought this could be acquired by well
these are industries I know really well
so any other day in 2012
I uh I had done really well in won't
mind careers and I decided to make a lot
of venture capital investments that they
made a billion dollar deal
so list when it was still morning to
towards five and wealth now it's all
details I don't have an appetite that
didn't work out but I was very intrigued
and then woman so I decided to create a
friendly office syndicate so I took my
own family office Canadian just build
and decided to create a syndicate and
the first deal we did was a company that
I was already very early investor and it
was doing local TRL
that was an accounting company in a kind
was off the technological substituent
floral for whatever QuickBooks which
also get credibly go so he took down a
hundred ten million dollar deal that we
don't feel Excel took that for you that
I don't look for over two thousand
twelve but it worked so well that I
decided to do others I decided to do
slack
the venture capitalist would have a good
deal but sometimes firms don't want to
take they should have the money for
though even though they want to bring in
other investors but they're always in
particularly back then and there's a lot
of reasons for punching back that's like
older to them did well and I was very
familiar with the industry that you know
back that in 2012 I was telling
everybody to get out of send a face it
was essentially a criminal enterprise
whenever you think of a dreesen which is
I'm not a credit of is at all
definitely not answer teen years created
much of what we have now but suddenly
getting created by them gave it a
language and put things into the
vernacular that I know this part of it
so took down slack took down box took
down a whole bunch of deal worked out
incredible and it just became I knew it
was gonna be super successful so we just
kept on building up the family office
syndicate and initially I brought in a
lot of overseas money because American
family offices did that on but we're not
interested in they wanted to do
different types of deals they wanted to
take that involved
you know maybe invest a billion a year
the industry definitely existed that so
I spent probably two years traveling all
over the Middle East here and they are
including meaning a lot of animals the
family offices means a lot of family
losses and I showed them my adult with
herself and went to every officer
somehow we did it and everybody loved it
these guys have a lot of odd just
staggering and they said okay you know
it could be a hundred or two hundred
million dollars for this it will match
everything that you want to do within
that niche because these guys are also
doing you know billion-dollar
agriculture deals where they're buying
smelting plants
that have contracts going fuller ten
years ridiculous so you know that worked
out really well and that's still now
such a big all my life but you know I
think I've died in it a kind of a
futurist someone so after we cashed
after I got out somewhat of trying to
book day I wanted to figure out how what
would happen next and they got very
interested to give you economy and wrote
up a lot about the gig economy and just
became probably the best guy on the
street who understood it but because I
wanted to replicate the co-employment
relationship trying to didn't find a lot
of gig economy as I thought could
sustain because all my companies have
always been profitable wasn't in
particularly interested and some guy
with a dream that went public and it's
still a dream it's just not what I do
I sleep in doing like a baby a too much
one Bob anybody or have them lie a
participating some type of books
illusions all my things are profitable
so made us a couple of small ambassadors
personally I think I gave a bunch of
people fifty venoth Hard Justice
speculate I learned I don't believe like
I like companies there's a big
difference people [ __ ] please don't
I can you can see something my rolodex
is incredible so I didn't want to
squander that on somebody who is running
misrepresent things or putting change
with the wing so it's very early
involved in company balcazar and mo
marvel thing about vacuum ibly is the
management and the actual share of a
that's where people I watched how they
were able to move as things change they
believe it was really incredible
including
transferwise because I mean I've seen
some people really who I was in Skype
and I've just seen people so I've seen
real entrepreneurs and I've seen those
entrepreneurs who have succeeded
becoming entrepreneurs between me they
went from being conquerors to
administrators incredibly so I do well
the sky balls
so now I've got my family office and a
lot of our investment thesis now is what
those following I am you know I've had a
large position in Tesla since the very
early days I've had a large position
Facebook was the very early dating that
started off just opportunistically
Woodstock accounting team they mix up
above dojo do the guy is Alexander the
Great together
just just remarkable very honest very
sincere I still think about it to this
day when I compare him to some of the
other social media companies and some of
the other tech people the difference
between him and when Twitter came to my
office to do those knowledge of sodunke
cheers for the after market I had in
that room the old goldman sachs post off
to learn who are Frank to be invested
just pause the other so but they did I
didn't introduce it by that you know
don't people are gone whatever
nevertheless I thought the Twitter
dodged the very brash we said no how are
you gonna do this how even if we died
and they felt they had a solution
because that they didn't need to express
to us because they were too smart and
they were wrong with everything both
Mark Zuckerberg is very sneaky so now my
thesis is something to now about three
years ago I started investing in defense
industry companies there's a lot of
reasons for it a lot of my teachers who
the world's just going to avoid I don't
like it but you don't have nuclear
weapons
just as a threat you don't develop
Michael nuclear's the Charter the
technology but you don't have anything
about maybe news or just as we actor the
world was gonna go to war
oh I love having large positions bearish
against time and it started out as that
because I said well who is going to be
part of this pool I've been there about
20 times and I know the culture there
really well and it's always happening
along itself deceive so I said there's
going to be a wall I could tell you
where it was going to be and who is
going to be on it and what properties
they were going to have them look footsy
refused and fought for and how is going
out so I also saw them infiltrating
American urban culture so I talked large
positions bullish log on and I don't
need what I have to deal with reality
and I knew China was going to experience
a shortage I didn't expect it to be as
severe as employees it had to become
more severe I increased my positions of
countries around the world I took
physical inventories of pennies in a
whole bunch of other things in both ways
along with actual some of our family
walking people one of the things that's
really interesting to me is you come out
of a world that I'll describe as kind of
Wall Street heavy right in terms of very
finance driven very much kind of public
markets but you found a lot of success
in investing in these private companies
in more of a venture capital model yeah
today you have a family office that's
highly successful you're able to have
called public private investments in the
public markets you have taken very large
positions in Tesla Boeing Lockheed great
kind of like you're describing what we
put in category of like innovation and
also yeah that's what we are that's
right so you've got kind of these two
buckets of innovation you've got defense
but defense is innovation the course
defense
innovation is what was the countries the
armies that one won because of their
innovation
of course well and I guess what what is
the surprising part right and I'm
cheating because you and I have talked
about this before and you kind of
describe some of it is in that
innovation bucket defense is kind of a
subset of it you also have things like
Tesla which obviously has has kind of
taken the lead on the electric vehicle
side but you don't have exposure to
Amazon and I think you've got a very
unique value of why you've chosen to not
take a position in Amazon so maybe talk
through a little bit of you know the
logic behind I think when people hear
somebody who's been successful over and
over and over again they wonder you know
I've lost money also of course so maybe
talk a little bit about Amazon and kind
of what the thesis there was to actually
avoid investing but let me go backwards
a little bit then to give you some
context on Amazon and also to be a
little bit more responsive to the
innovation defenses and tests as well so
you know part of my thesis was how
expensive innovation is in the United
States and I'm not talking about
Facebook coming out with an app Google
doing some hey I I don't mean to knock
and heal the people that are doing that
but that's low hanging fruit that's
still really you know Facebook training
it to seek to read me deserve so they
can take out to eat whatever I want to
inform robotic system is actually simple
stuff I don't need to be announced back
but it's kinetics low-hanging fruit
innovation in the United States is high
hanging fruit is extraordinarily
expensive you need really big team so
quantum computing is also something you
need teleportation community is these
are really high hanging 50 people and
you're not going to have them working
remotely you need 50 people and you've
gotta have proximity to them you know
you better forget about looking over
their shoulders that's not how you
measure their performance they it's
highly complex if you're not getting
these people for $150,000 a year and how
[Music]
a lot of it is also spinning out of here
to say whether I like listen we don't
have the internal bandwidth to be able
to do this you don't have an olive
charge that commits it oh and I became
an invest in a lot of those companies
because you'll say listen if you have a
couple of cryptologist and we're
interested in doing this but these the
general that's been currently the CEO of
this venture within the NSA has no idea
what he's doing
he'll be like and we can't devote any we
can't allocate any more internal
resources like so they would spit it out
and I would give them usually three
million and these companies don't go
from seed to be round
oh they basically go for seed pods say
they go from anywhere they just suck up
a lot of smart money they don't want to
take you mentioned half of the money
they've taken a lot of Zonk about China
came to there really are you thinking a
lot of Bloomberg think and a lot of
things to tell but those are past the
best it's not the very Chinese are going
to touch anything oh I think you tell us
about it touch me so you know you need
to scale these companies so you can see
how expensive intubation is because as
those companies both to see to see
overnight you now see the problems
they're trying to solve
it's ridiculous when you see the defense
industry you see the f-35 you see some
of these other things or you know the
Apache six befores these are highly
complex problems but do you have an
understanding that the role is going to
have a thousand drones lighting up the
sky you're talking to Scott and one of
them you're gonna have a payload that's
a biological weapon that some kid
created in this general plan or finding
that one out of a thousand it's not a
couple of kids you know in their
basement writing a highly complex
problem and maybe most about problems of
data how to identify which is the friend
or which is the flow because what
happens if you've got a thousand drones
one of them's got this huge payload and
it's following in a couple of 747s what
do you do then if you take out one
you're going to take out the friend also
and what if you don't know if that
passed your plane is
before this and how do you with off
there's just so much like really highly
complex uh so and that's also true
otezla I don't think of Tesla's normal
company it never did uh one of the
largest shareholders
was a good friend and in fact one of the
old Goldman Sachs all stores and I
persuaded him into faceball I think it's
sixty dollars or something and uh maybe
2030 so he persuaded me to increase
positions in Tesla and he kind of gave
me a real roadmap of what it is
Elon also used to come to the Sequoia
and you will all be in July so I had a
chance to speak and it's not a nautical
just as Amazon is not it so it's just
nothing if you have a if you have a
concept of anything in Queen and what
happens you you've got to build off the
back engine and so that's what I think
they're they're building off however I
think I think about a more the back end
that's doing not just the fulfillment of
it but also all the reconciliation to
make this thing work and because those
existing pieces weren't there they had
the Builder
it's incredible leadership Northland
Alice SpaceX you couldn't do that until
recently the United States going to do
what they're doing
Indy you can do a little bit of Bulacan
redundancy ridiculous so so now go
unfollowed you to happen is on Amazon
there's not really solving it's not
really solving a highly complex Club
there's not really a lot of innovation
you know there's a lot of odds but I'll
get to that that's been adopted by a lot
of Wall Street a lot of our tech kids
because Amazon is doing first world
again they're very good in it and I
literally mean first of all propaganda
they're doing american-style propaganda
they've got a lot of embedded
journalists
biz insider and such that are out there
I can't just turned on the light so
their that are there a cop
is really seizing the opportunity means
with weed within our own Congress
whether their own political
establishment and also fulfilling kind
of an oligarchy wish list so he saw
where the world was going and he just
built that for them so he saw that in
actuality the world wasn't was no longer
fragment right
the fragmenting had occurred in my
generation which was all the big
conglomerates started spinning things
off everything they bought in the
eighties so to speak waste management
companies and everything they now
started spinning off and that's what
Mike Milken is doing so Jeff was doing
the exact is doing the exact opposite
he's defragment and he's doing it in a
form of a monopsony but monopsony has
always been called monopoly and in doing
what he's doing he's just creating an
absolutely destruction but that's what
our power structure now demands it's no
longer just an issue of shareholder
return it's it's it's malicious how do
you balance the idea between a company
like Amazon which has been one of the
best performing stocks and I don't know
yeah yeah but has when you measure it
from like a innovative product and
revenue generation standpoint it has
been quote-unquote productive but to
your point by them being productive and
successful you're basically making the
argument that they're causing
destruction in the rest of the market
right so how do you balance those on
like a net basis and how do you just
think of it from a mental framework
standpoint so no one here I decided to
not buy the stock but I you know I knew
it was gonna increase many-fold but I
didn't want to be complicit to one of
these do it while is you know defensive
misleading will those bombs have to drop
so then those planes are gonna shoot at
something there's also so much
innovation that's going on that if we
don't innovate then our opponents will
drop their bombs on us and we need if
we're gonna have a space force we need
to create the technology that
but so Amazon their innovation is more
in the propaganda and how they've been
able to establish a foothold and a lot
of what made them great so to speak was
the acquisition of AWS and that those
margins really started eroding when
Aslan came into the marketplace a lot of
shares so there's it's a very complex
story with Amazon because Amazon it is
not a company it's a country to think
about it as a company is unpersuasive it
is you know my thesis has always been
that or since I was about 15 if those
that that sovereignty is is changing but
even then I could see evidence of it
then we were going from the territorial
sovereignty to a functional sovereignty
and you could see that more with what
Amazon is doing what Facebook and Google
is do it so right now people are
protesting in their line right they're
doing people are doing very harmful
things the girls are doing fantastic but
the destructive part of it which is is
they're tearing down what they what is
available to them they're tearing down
the merchants BOM is sweet because they
could not tear down Amazon Amazon does
not have those physical locations we can
break down they've got some data centers
which if they even decide to approach no
don't get shot down and you'll never
hear about it out soon guaranteed same
with baseball it's not a lot of people
but Bill they're gonna it's a third it's
a it's a first world country I didn't
want to participate in that but I saw it
happen so I saw the world defragmenting
I saw the idea of sovereignty really
changing over and now people are seeing
it and in a year or two it's not even
going to be you'll be just as happy to
exchange Amazon credits as law or the
American dollar
for some people if you can pay your rent
in facebook coin F clock Amazon and your
landlord accepts it what distinguishes
the to it so I guess as part of that
there's a lot of people who listen who
are huge believers in Bitcoin
specifically and kind of the
digitization of money all these things
how do you kind of think through the
corporates entering into the currency
competition the sovereign nations
digitizing their currencies and then
kind of these separation of State and
money something like a Bitcoin okay so
let me go back to my own background
Bigpoint so I was involved in the
company polkas on which was a very early
period appear right so there was Napster
there was long lawyer that was good off
and without getting too much in depth
into cos ah I I saw Hillary Rosen go on
to the RIAA the recording artist and I
saw all that use Metallica this front
whatever but hilary rosen just destroyed
that industry because government cannot
catch up legislation cannot catch up
with technology so they have to destroy
it
and they may have to take ownership of
it which is what's happening with
facebook now you know they're they had
to destroy now what they're rebuilding
is you know this horrible incarnation so
when when Kazaa got shut down
I I still are still innocent I became
very anti status and when Bitcoin came
out but you loved it because we didn't
have funding and we didn't have big boys
we had again I think it was called like
Eagles
yes equivalent so that double pending
problem and then you know the idea of
big bling and I still love it I'm no
longer an organ event I think I may have
something locally but I meant the
secretly guys and to see guys they were
introduced me to John Hopkins
i ball cash now but I I love it it's
just not for me it's not my risk
appetite but it is the future that we're
going to live in so if you were asked
how that is important like thesis I
would say well there's going to be all
two types of money and I think you had
to do you met w-wha moves on please just
off the charts brilliant with this and
can really could me bikini event these
things better than I can in terms of
what that what that is but we're both on
the exact same asylum that's what it's
gonna be
she just looks little opportunity this
way so it's gonna be more people's nor
rich people eccentric rich people's
money is going to be gold as we
discussed before buried in the backyard
and it's going to be the American dollar
in poor people's money is going to be
these are tertiary secondary and
tertiary type of coins is something that
there's going to be a Fed coin which
will be a dolphin dollar swap and you're
not going to see you know if it's it's
gonna trade out the dollar would so
you're gonna see you perfectly
very soon sure and then whoever becomes
president next will probably be a part
of that if you've so it's gonna be poor
people's money than rich people he knows
for an average middle-class person
whether they get paid and scribble
essentially as long as they can go to
the company story and music purchases
now the handicap is that you can buy a
property in alternately you can you buy
your house in Hawaii well that person is
perhaps take it yeah but when you're
talking about a hundred million dollar
is a property so it's not going to be
ever sticky for that you know they they
want they want to go into Gaza you want
to bury at the back dog but they were
going to cancel on premium so it's
I mean I cashed out I'm still wearing
some funds that happen and what's
interesting to me as we've talked more
and more is you're very knowledgeable
when it comes to kind of the direction
that a lot of this is playing out you
understand the players in the market but
you are one of the rare people who
crosses over and you're still a very
bullish person when it comes to natural
commodities as well right so I bought
America but of course but but I think
that there's a lot of people or at least
there's a narrative that is emerging
where there's a lot of people who are
trying to draw a line in the sand
between kind of the digital commodities
if you will all of these new tokens and
assets and then the legacy commodities
right so like gold verse Bitcoin is is a
very easy one and you can kind of go
through all of them but you were either
easy to kind of on a spreadsheet perhaps
kind of have a column a and column B and
you know you can be very selective about
what you're going to include with end of
those fields but it's it's not one it's
a kind of a reckless comparison but yeah
okay yeah and so it may be talk a little
bit of what you've done in the natural
commodity space and kind of what the
thesis there is yeah so I you know for
full disclosure I have physical
inventory of gold I've tried other
metals but you know they're heavy and
you have to even just only you know it's
better than itself and it's not an issue
of having an appetite for risk and so
you got to pay for that risk so it kind
of affects them so you know in terms of
gold the modak just goes into kind of
this idea of which people are going in
for people's gold is something you can
bury in your back yard so I don't see it
being a lot of transactions Oh with it I
don't see it just placing the dollar or
anything else I see on our political and
business elites just with their own for
Knox's and particularly money that's
being illegally transferred overseas
that's
so uh I also have physical so I in terms
of America Beijing just I've been for
thirty years and I never sold test nor
when I had some of the top Shore thought
on TV and calling me up saying would you
please sell it because it's going to
crash it was a three hundred in crash
the two hundred and you know I knew
there was going to be a short weeks that
guy that has been done it before so I
you know I expect Wars I expect these
things to happen tonight
you know I speak Mandarin I have a very
deep familiarity with China and I think
I'm going to expect the world where is
it gonna happen it's not gonna happen on
our in America about two oceans it was
just blast geographically we don't have
even with our divisions now we don't
have what's required to engage in a war
somebody not to attack and you know it's
very evident it was going to be time I
mean just very ugly what they were
building out and then just kind of the
vulnerabilities of South China Sea in
their belligerence in South China Sea
and because I was so interested in
defense what they were doing their own
defense technology they're all
mentioning technology I think America's
but what they were doing with with
things I was very interested in so then
I asked my analyst to go a few clicks
deeper and we saw how we could kind of
exploit that even as an opportunity one
most of the bearish on and we held those
positions laws other offices family
offices and hedge funds did it but I
won't have any investors I'm an investor
doesn't have to take directly it really
matter to me knew I wasn't losing
everything but I have you know if I do I
have all three people to call say hey
you know you're not gonna maybe don't
buy that car tomorrow right so and I
don't have exposure or fiduciary type of
thing other things myself so the very
positions on the wand isn't and I also
as madness where there was kind of born
ability with supply chains and other
things that kind of express themselves
lead to the ones actually and you know
we were after the Smithfield purchase
which was this big company that was
acquired by the German easy to say but I
saw them with their but actually saw
what your shortages barring why we got
two clicks deep branch you know they're
all corruption of their land and their
water which was probably forever Morgan
be repairable but how they needed to
kind of important sort of things going
on so overseas I acquired these things
can be compact and that held those
positions and in you know swine flu
happy and I think we had a while and we
called up a lot of other a lot of page
he said hey long China's depleting their
concern they're gonna have to go
overseas to go to Africa block by other
countries bribe the people to deprive
the president's the Prime Minister is to
empty their reserves and transport them
so that's going to be painful on gold
I'm not going to pay for that picture so
you know I believe in Florida goes
though the metal I'm not a gold layer
but you have to because wealth is now
how the concept of wealth has changed
forever or we've grown up in the mirror
of anything you wear
there's its own good opportunity right
no you know the worst kid are with a
little bit of luck but just I included
my my my mother who came down he doesn't
and he was one of the people came down
from the mountain complex bothered
social revolution and he now has to hit
to go they both graduated so that's
going to become increasingly more
difficult to have that type of economic
inflation so now preserving one which
was before kind of biology over there
looking like a has changed considerably
because now it's not just about
preserving lawful requires kind of
tactical I'll go back detectable it
requires very very disciplined so like
part of this is what I enjoy talking so
much is like you've just thought about
many different disciplines very deeply
you're telling me before I was sort of
recording that these are not just
fly-by-night thoughts that kind of come
in and out of your head but you've been
writing a lot of stuff down as well they
talked to us just kind of from a high
level of like why are you spending so
much time right now and kind of the
midst of all this chaos writing so much
and in kind of like a daily log or
really kind of just putting these ideas
and thoughts down onto paper yes
interesting because the 2012 and all I
thought is pretty public I was massively
I'm you just clinically and vacations it
was all manage it was all that it was a
day it's been your entire life and your
compensation a lot of it has been on the
back end and now you know you cashed
everything basically one year on cash so
I'm massively depressed I read senators
I'm sure dissipate and I read his
letters to the service and for me is
like my own father speak so I learned
the concept of time right which is
something I never thought about before
but he moved on and how observe time
not just by your kids born older married
right in terms of in order for you to
observe time requiring its own
discipline
so I started keeping the daily law in
fact I've got it right there and it has
everything in it it's God
one time I woke up was on the way to
sleep how long they stay at bed for the
I meditate how many times an amenity did
i deceive myself that I deceive others
because the section is a very important
thing did I talk too much did I listen
you know these are things that have to
be there have to be the weirdness of a
bank it realize until I wanted to find
some type of dedication so I had already
had an appreciation for laws I have kept
them every day
and but Cokely happen and I saw does it
not all my theories but I saw that the
world is Happy's changing so quickly and
so violently that the mind could not
copy it you think you can you think you
remember things from Kovac you don't
I've kept a detailed log that right now
is about ten dollars a day I've now
enlisted other people to help young but
it is extremely detailed and are you
interested why I did this but it Cove it
absolutely okay well George Soros has a
gets a bad laugh people should really
read him some of his stuff and I've been
lucky to know him and his uh his own
philanthropy in yoga Swiss Institute are
all the guards are complex things right
and so he has a theory of reflexivity
which is brilliant and I learned about
him in 2012 when I was trying to figure
out my own investment on the thesis and
I needed it I needed a better vocabulary
and a better way of thinking about it
and they you know the PDF of it is
adequate it's a little bit tedious but
the videos on YouTube are incredible
and what he talked about was positive
and negative feedback and he actually
used the instance of social media and
needs so he was talking about it even in
the current environment about how media
can and will lie you and the tools that
he uses and why in the behavioral
sciences and how it can we observe or
not be observed and how look at it as a
disembodied intellect so that's what I
wanted to do because I knew that you
know we were seeing the fastest ball of
a power and human history but I also saw
a meanie of the school so he's got this
theory that in behavioral science is
that the mind can only hold actively
about six thoughts at a time and what
the media does is they can continually
Wilma bar you with information with
mother completely bombard you with
thoughts so that these thoughts are all
you have in front of your mind right
that's what you've got so all that
matters is that is it they overwhelm
those sports and it doesn't matter if
yesterday's thought was a lie because it
doesn't exist there anymore
today's thoughts exist there does that
make sense to you it does so I wanted to
observe coving in the way that they were
lying about it because I knew system I
mean nationally anybody human being long
I saw some of your podcast and three
months ago some of you have gas pump in
Sweden why I never once oh and I tried
to share that when people on Twitter
actually because I never was and I just
couldn't find any people that were all
sympathetic to hike that battle but I'm
so I kept the log because people weren't
and I wanted to observe the way the
medium was creating this because it's no
longer there's no Achon ski no one
Chomsky type of effect with
manufacturing consent and that is
primitive you're talking about
Mesolithic oh you know you're talking
about where there's only five media
corporations and there's only
essentially three we type providers like
or I don't know whatever it is however
it gets through the pipes and there's
only a couple of you know
ESPN's and Disney then in fact is in the
information so how those five
corporations interests just bullshitting
everybody they wanted to lock everybody
up and then why they want to lock
everybody up and I was just watching
everything and I'll give you an example
of that a month ago everything that you
were seeing on TV was images of the
Great Recession and the Great Depression
then they showed more lines and food
bank let me tell you I do a model of
philanthropy and I do a lot with local
development so my wife is doing right
now much a lot I mean a little bit I
don't mean to embellish you a lot behind
this particular schism watch TV new game
she was a coupons I mean she's actually
helping people so I knew that the job
market was still good and that actually
people stay free right they weren't
persuaded by this they knew that being
was lying to him so I uh
I kept the log of all of it I kept a log
of chloroquine I kept a log of Tom Hanks
do you know anything about Tom Hanks I
know that he was one of the first
celebrities to uh actually be confirmed
to have coronavirus and he's so loved
that uh I think people really were kind
of like whoa [ __ ] this might be actually
pay attention to if Tom Hanks has it
okay so let me interrogate you a little
bit cuz I'm fascinated - was he
confirmed to have kool-aid I don't know
I don't recall I mean I don't recall
yeah so he him and uh I believe it's
Rita is his wife right they supposedly
both were confirmed to have Co vid and
they were I want to say in Australia but
don't hold me to that there were some
where and and took a test and were
confirmed and then basically you know
two weeks later three weeks later
whatever came out and said hey you know
we survived this which again is to your
point I think when a celebrity or
somebody who is well known it was like
the NBA players right oh my god NBA
players have tested positive from a
mathematical standpoint there should be
no difference in gravity
of importance based on what you do in
life how much money you have or anything
like that when it comes from a
qualitative standpoint the fact that you
know a rich person or a famous person
could get this I think drives more fear
when it comes to something like a virus
or things that are just well not
understood science just I just want to
understand kind of your emotions
attached to it not going Marshall know
but just kind of your Howie Howie how
your brain kind of synthesizes what's no
longer ahead of me so I'm gonna just ask
you a couple questions was he confirmed
to have it I mean did you oh I know he
revealed that he had it and perhaps the
test being positive is a confirmation
but being a celebrity I don't think that
was a persuasive Leo there was his
doctors of the Clarett he wasn't I mean
we don't see a snap on how do you think
he got Kobrin how do you think he would
I have no clue is it because he has a
lot of exposure to people and he does a
lot of selfies because that was kind of
the calm it's definitely possible right
if I remember correctly I think that
there were stories saying that he was
like filming a movie or preparing to
film a movie and the whole logic was oh
that's because he's running into people
all day long and kind of engaging that
way but but I don't think that they ever
came out and said you know this is how
he got it yeah so what do you think has
more exposure would have more exposure
to Kobe a retail well that hospitality
would be where Tom Hanks who do you
think has more exposure to people more
interactions with people Tom Hanks the
CEO of the most one of the most powerful
companies in the world Cole Tom or a
retail worker making $15 an hour behind
a shoe at the store a hospitality who
has more exposure I'll tell you that the
throughout the entire thing every time I
went to the grocery store the the
cashier at the grocery store I was in
amazement at the same people there every
single day you know day in day out
because they had to interact with you
know hundreds of people
if not more on a daily basis throughout
this entire thing for weeks on it but
they didn't have it okay but so let me
ask you another question there may be
statistically they did almost
statistically doesn't seem to be
critical and I think at a time that what
day what day what month do you think
what month did Tom Hanks reveal he had
tested positive for codons
I don't remember but I think and the end
of March
sometime in there if I if I remember
correctly and then you discuss the NBA
when did the NBA reveal that one of
their players had tested positive and
the Stompa season yeah it was early it
was like mid mid to late March okay so
it was the NBA first name topics right I
don't remember but yeah something like
that
but you remember them both of them that
Tom Hanks had kovaydin you remember that
the NBA how to play with coach you
remember both of those but not the facts
of it right because that's your fact oh
yeah that's what that's what skill is in
your mind someplace and it's just been
filed away it's not something that you
talked about um Kovac started right
there the awareness of Coleman as a well
pandemic doesn't have revelation but the
awareness of the fullness of the threat
of Hogan started about when what do you
think I think in the u.s. no one really
took it seriously till March but I think
globally you know I think I remember I
got on a fight in January was like third
week of January maybe and I put a mask
on and I was actually just telling
someone recently that the warning sign I
should have paid attention to but didn't
understand that it was a warning sign is
when I went to get a mask in New York
City they were out of all the n95 masks
at the store so now that was
prophylactic of you and wise and I know
you know I saw your interview with
Balaji and I know that he was very your
only advocate of the prophylactic
measure so let me just understand the
sequence of events right January you are
you became a
Arabic and he said this is going to be a
problem and some of you are friends who
are better observers of these things
although not academically qualified but
enough on and periphery of being and
qualified to just make this type of and
what information do you think they were
gathered just often I mean where are
they getting it from videos do you think
that those videos of people chopping
down in China do you think that had an
influence on people's perception of the
death I mean you remember those videos
Terry oh I I think that the and this
will be a problem going forward but
specifically was a very obvious during
the kovat stuff was I remember multiple
times January February into March and
April saying look the data that we are
being told you have to question for
let's say three or four different
perspectives and the questioning isn't I
think that it's overinflated or
underfoot it's actually I don't know
right because you can actually make an
argument that certain data points are
overinflated certain data points are
under-inflated but what ends up
happening is it became this um I don't
know just emotional thing where people
began to tell themselves stories that
they wanted to hear and they found the
data that supported that story right and
that worked for people in both camps
those for or against it so let me let me
provide a little bit of forensics that
is absolutely correct so I'm gonna strip
the emotions out of it I'm gonna look at
is that disembodied okay so I'm gonna
look at how true actually corresponds to
fact and place those and not these six
thoughts that were in my head and trying
to invoke them down so the the videos of
China was coming out in January and
people dropping dead in social and
the way they were quarantine people also
started coming out there the violence
how they were doing which was also
around the same time as the bias which
I'm sure you remember lost and I'm
because I'm so familiar with China kanji
in terms of China particularly social
although I don't intrude any but I'm
very aware though I know that there are
a lot of lights on the mainland
thank you didn't see because people
weren't getting paid because there was a
shortage on there was a lot of riots as
creditors can no more no longer have the
capital to continue giving in to debtors
because they don't have their own dollar
denominated so the Sampo generating
right now I have this a timeline of
everything I mean China the US the media
the who I can't even tell you how much
I've got everything crominus
so I'm gonna bore you with this but it's
kind of interesting I like interrogating
people on this so the panic began de
Blasio is a friend I've been with for 20
years I'm not going to look at him as a
person I'm gonna look at the politician
in early March that everyone don't see a
blue eye and he even recommended a movie
in the trailer which was clearly
intended to be a snipe and at the same
time as health commissioner's and you
know hang out with everybody have a good
time to be in March and notice he was
saying the same thing you know they were
saying I think they were learning to be
in places that were just and they called
it essentially be its consequences the
equivalent on the flip they didn't
comically but they just kind of the
inference was that you know she has
happened okay so just go out and enjoy
life so March 11
imperial employed comes out he'll
Ferguson who has a very checkered past
and March 11th well came out right
before that but let me just begin with
much of that is Angela Merkel comes out
in his speech it shocked the world
literally look up the headline it
shocked the world authority look up
anything and she's doing something and I
don't have any fun
regulations like 200 million people in
America affected and 2.2 million
Americans would die unless certain
measures were taken but it's going to be
devastating and she called it a war on
she said we Germany has experienced
something like this and throw me a
frickin stain whatever she says do the
office okay
truly and as an investor I can tell you
whatever she said do the office and
you'll make it food so March 11 Angela
Merkel comes out that there's a much
more than watch well as I recall I'm
just going to say Marshall Lerner that
could be offered it was all over the
newspapers everywhere it was even the
the cover of the intercept which is
allegedly this liberal type of thing
just because sometimes they'll criticize
Hillary later
but whatever or sometimes they'll
defense crumble with everybody I had
some a subscription anyway but it was
their cover a million people are going
to die but all of ours like people like
this year so at least when they're not
working they like the Martha consumer
new look but so on that same day on that
same day Tom Hanks him down as he had a
corona blonde I think the pot I think in
Australia they were like at that time
and again I don't have the same for me
but there was like four people with the
virus Mall in Australia him agreed over
two of them it's insane that same guy
the NBA went through what they made
their you know revelation so I believe
it was even about 24 hour and again this
is all chronicle the thickness and I
have a rigid but Tom Hanks is one of
those recognizable people in humanity I
mean he's no Tom Cruise
but Tom Hanks is you know yes who he is
right
he's you know an eight losses you know
so the Oviatt space means so and the NBA
is ESPN
Disney soldier it's a well-recognized
right around the world everybody knows
with the India
everybody knows who shot hopefully clean
the bar I think they've lost a minister
so uh that's a lot of media exposure all
at once right that kind of a Barger
Headley do you think that those six
thoughts became a thousand thoughts and
six the number in your head worth so
with that said the next time we heard of
Hanks was when in April I forget the
date I think it was May 24th or whatever
was I mean I'm just looking I don't
think you remember all the headlines
against chloroquine right and it was a
very heavy concentration my two-week
period and it was everywhere did you
agree with that absolutely absolutely
going back to my theories of things it
was filling up those six thoughts right
Rita Wilson announces that she ignored
for Oakland and it was horrible
and it was like the one of the worst
experience she's ever had in life
she's not even swore but had any if it
did any good
some died most likely for is Latino
drinks fish tanks something because
Trump said they're also skiing so the
imagery that's going on in the brain so
I'm keeping this Kovac dog because all
of this has to be remembered his stories
I thought they remember any of this
journalists journals will never write on
what we're experiencing now and if they
do it's the tiniest sliver
they're never gonna write a system view
in journalism which has been a love of
my life and my mentors is never gonna
recover in the way that you grew up you
grew up with a dad or these handsome
appearance of impartiality and authority
that's gone that's never coming back so
I had to be not dying so I had already
had this for my own daily while shaking
about half an hour a day and I still
happen one day
what you and I had coffee and I remember
using bad language and I was just about
the one Indian over and if it is that
language I never use it so but I was
saying horrible words a lot so as soon
as soon as I was doing it that my loving
I was like there was a formal delusion
why would you use bad language I mean
it's just another way they manifest
himself but why was I using such bad
language how much stop awareness that I
lose that I was using the language that
I've used very frequent but I recall
using that's what we're writing that
down and why do they do that
how's my listening trapshooters business
are you like other people I have my good
life and it feels to me like documenting
it has value do you think that you'll go
back and read it six months from now a
year from now like what's the what's the
value in the future of doing it now yeah
yeah well I'm doing it right now for me
right but I'm also including it a
science fiction story and because so
much information right just like those
six thoughts that source before my
disappearing the behavioral scientists I
have a lot of stones sticks thoughts in
my piece I mean just a timeline for the
China is about 40 slides you know each
of them are very overwhelming I think
they're gonna need those six thoughts
and people already have their other
competing six thoughts right so I
include a lot of human as an action and
but at the same time a renaissance
fictions to it and it's done in a way
that relaxes the mind so now you've got
those six thoughts of your mind them you
know mine are competing for once
CNN put in your brain but I'm also
trying to give you some relief so you've
got all these negative feedback loops
I'm trying to let your mind restore some
type of an equilibrium with this really
interesting just absurd fascinating
science fiction story that is awesome
and
not immature it's kind of a chunky beach
novel that's only maybe gonna be 5,000
words it's amazing it's just this
amazing area that asked it effect it's
amazing it's about Superman by the way
but he's never Superman he's parking
whatever but but do you want to publish
this as a book or is this something
that's just for you as a creative
exercise it's a good question I'm not
sure it's become such an obsession for
me because we're just don't you know
it's the fastest rollable power in
history and you know there's a lot of
politics going on and there's a lot of
protest and there's a lot of bees for
that that is a demand there's a lot of
counting down statues and losing
butterflies we even just losing
everything that needs my life special
I mean just everything every thing that
made my life so special Nancy lost half
a big son of a family that's on half the
potion to the ninth seat and you're
losing on history because Christopher
Columbus brought us all this from Spain
because there was a requirement of
conversion and he himself was likely
tuition it's just so Terry are no
statues is it's not it's not it is not
being done by the victims of the
oppressive I think it's being done by
the oppressor and once that history is
gone America will never be able to
restore itself because these are the
idiots that might see at all doing these
things you know they know means of
socials and there's something web blog
that they read and whatever else that
aren't just idiotic I mean I realize
it's it's unrecognizable so they have no
intellectual ability nor the historical
record needed to build any type of an
operable what I call a
operating system so what if instead
happens is we have these mega
corporations that again have gone from
kind of a territorial solitude to a
functional one where we've exchanged a
constitution for a Terms of Service and
we've seen that with black lives matter
where everyone it's that and whether the
prize is virtuous or not in some
political parties and type of thing
because I don't really get into these
kind of things but it's a lot of wedding
pits and these white kids weren't
infeasible there are the families for
facebook and so Facebook is changing
over at Google is taking work Amazon is
taking notes or whatever was left
whatever artifacts was left of he tell
stories and have cached for inductions
and everything else is being taken away
and I wanted to document this so I might
turn it into a movie I don't know I
don't know I'm under I mean I might turn
angel baby I might just want some dyes
and there's a lot of people or qualified
to do or am I just returning to a
graphic novel or I love it I'm gonna
stop find it whatever it is
I'm gonna and I've known a lot of stuff
like I don't want a nickel from anybody
ever I love it I love it
before I wrap up I was asked the same
two questions to everyone first one is
what is the most important book you've
ever read oh that's easy
I'll actually to choice now between I'm
gonna actually say instead of the
letters to it because my I didn't have
those lessons growing up I didn't happen
and that was how I acquired all that
wisdom and fatherly advice and it's also
stuck with me because of the letter you
know it was such an amazing mentor
rotation just I don't have you better I
have not no worth it yeah yeah and I
would say one of the other authors with
innovate is Epictetus of Beaver meadow
Matias
I have not tell every young person you
know to read Seneca or without needing
to adopt stories I just read this and we
epictetus because if if somebody as a
youth have given me up of Tina's my life
would have been my corporal life would
have been much different because the
role is so violent back then it was
about how to stay alive in a very
violent times so in a corporate
environment although you're not going to
be killed if you want to succeed
it requires that same type of diplomacy
we are in it somehow to communicate
things and how to respect hierarchies
organizational charts it just remarkable
lessons because back then there you know
see them killing them on a whim or a
senator will kill you on a whim
literally on a whim if they want to get
property and you weren't in their favor
they would and they had their own
volition so it was difficult to stay
alive and a required effort to stay
alive so I would say okay I I love it
what uh we think about aliens believer
or non-believer Oh what do you mean by
aliens you tell me how you define it
well I think of a life on another planet
is that that's a fair definition you
think that exists I think we're going to
encounter much sooner than people think
but I think at that time line look like
I think it's going to present problems
for Humanity because they're gonna be
smarter than us when we encounter them
they're gonna be much smarter than their
realities will be much different than
notes in a way that we can accomplish so
you know I read science fiction books
and I like them and I like teleportation
all this type of stuff but that's the
human experience which is kind of it
it's only to be on it because even with
space Wars of humanity will be living in
space by 2013 and 2016
hotels in space hundreds of thousands of
people that 2016 it's still going to be
an acute experience it's still going to
be your experiences
in space and although those experiences
are going to change with these you know
generation in whatever at first it's the
mind can only comprehend so much but
very imperfect things and our AI is
built upon human right we're talking
about something just be comprehensibly
more advanced in terms of its complete
intelligence then Allah said there's no
way of law here I'm going to probably
hit it so hopefully our interactions
will be all they'll be sweet
hopefully they'll be kind to us I think
no I think don't meet us before we need
them but they're not going to come here
to rip our some take our dilithium
crystal it's a benign already eat us I
tend to think that you're probably more
right than than not what um you could
ask me one question to wrap up what uh
what's the one question you have and ask
you to question sure what is your
favorite book what book
no excuse me let me take that bomb what
book do you feel has had the most
influence in you as you read it so I'm
cheating because I've thought a lot
about this obviously when I asked the
question
there was three books that I read
simultaneously I'm sorry sequentially at
the age of 20 years old while I was
deployed to our rocks a lot of time to
kind of sit around read think all that
kind of stuff and I read Rich Dad Poor
Dad richest man in Babylon and thinking
Grow Rich and the reason why I think
those three books kind of together at
that time in life was it changed the way
I thought right it kind of was a
reprogramming if you will just about
here is how work and money and kind of
all these things in life
it's very opposite I think to kind of a
traditional education and so if you read
it too early you're almost not mature
enough to kind of take it seriously if I
were to read it too late in life I
probably would have kind of been set in
my ways and so it was one of these kind
of serendipitous things of those three
books together at that
point in life like set me in probably a
different direction than I would have
gone so I think that's probably it you
know not even close compared to anything
else that's very interesting now
particularly thinking grow edged did
this give you a perspective and a
rationale not just a perspective but a
complete kind of system of thought right
that's where it is that you feel like do
your parents give that to you I mean had
you have any slivers of that before did
you have any system you on that before
what I think that my parents definitely
never like set me or my brothers down
and we're like let us teach you
something
the one thing that now being older
having the the kind of wherewithal to
had the conversation my parents about
like hey why did you do certain things
when we were growing up my father was
adamant about not giving us an allowance
and I remember you know us as kids being
like hey every kid i knows got an
allowance like basically you're cheating
us out of our god-given right to you
know have 20 bucks to go to the movies
right yeah and what he would say to us
is if you want money I'm happy to give
you money but come ask me and I will
tell you what you need to do in order to
earn the money and so for us it was just
you know dad being an [ __ ] basically
right and trying to give us a be a be
difficult but really what he was
teaching us was look if you want the 20
bucks ago the movie theater go outside
rake the leaves right and kind of just
instilling in us this almost
subconscious manner of like if you do
work you can earn money and so I think
that like after reading those books it
was one of these things where like you
started to connect some dots that maybe
weren't as obvious beforehand and then
after the fact being able to have the
conversation and him being like yeah
look I know you guys thought I was just
being difficult but like I put a little
bit of thought into it
right that I wasn't you know completely
flying at the edge of my seat there so I
don't I don't think it was kind of
formal education I think it was more of
you know trying to get ideas into for
him five sons who pretty hard-headed
you can't really sit them down in the
classroom style you got to kind of do it
in other ways number one okay even
though there was a follower to that it
was like Joe Warren hi what's number two
hey so number two I wasn't actually
anticipating asking I don't think I've
asked people before brother I'm very
intrigued and maybe it's because I'm
also wondering about myself but if if
you were to show your eyes now you have
an awareness that I'm gonna watch you
and whoever's launching this is watching
me so I'm gonna ask you two questions
but they're like when you shut your eyes
your mind is going to travel a little
bit in time you can remember you I have
to do this today
yep acts a little bit so we can quickly
get beyond that because I know I want to
be a 70-ton so mulashi - quickly as you
can you can time travel a little bit and
and you're gonna think about some ones
that have to happen well I'm very
interested in is how what your own
identity is so I ask yourself in your
idea show I am a person who and then
filling in and then as that's your own I
get any rate and then I'm also very
interested in how you want others to
perceive you so while your eyes are
showing and everyone's watching me right
you're kind of vulnerable how do you
want Adam and everybody else how do you
want us what is your identity so I think
of myself you know I you know I am the
type of person who's grateful in sees
not as sent let me come let me just
clarify that and then wait layer while
you're within down relax with the state
of mind is I want people to think of me
as a person who yep so I've probably
thought about this more than most people
under the guise of I
think one of the greatest
vulnerabilities and actual weaknesses of
American society and just more generally
globally is most people answer that
question with some adjectives or some
occupation right and I've said it
publicly before but I actually think one
of the greatest advantages in life is to
attach your identity to your own name
and what I mean by that is let's take
corporate America right so if you work
in corporate America most people will
say when they when they meet you right
they will very quickly in the
conversation explain where they work or
what their role is right and that is
something that gives them a point of
pride it's a point that gives them
identity it's a point that gives them
something to kind of hang their hat on
right and it gives them importance in a
conversation if you then go to other
types of occupations it might be less
likely that they attach identity to the
workplace or the title in terms of like
the actual I'm a managing director or
AMA you know manager or whatever but it
is the job that they do so you may get
somebody who says I'm a I'm a
entrepreneur or I'm a you know banker or
whatever that the occupation is not
necessarily tied to the location I tend
to think that the people who I find most
gratifying spending time with in life
and I think kind of have the the best
advantage is the people who say my name
is Anthony Pollyanna and that's it
right that is the identity is it's it's
their name and the reason why I think
that is because you can strip away
everything else but you can't take away
them write them as an individual as
their name etc and so it kind of is this
weird thing where your whole life you're
conditioned to care about and put
importance on all of those adjectives
all those occupations and roles and all
this kind of stuff but if you're able to
eventually get to the point where you
can say I'm actually just comfortable
being me without any of that there's
this element of
it's kind of like an F you mental state
right of just being able to say like I
actually don't care what you think about
what job I do or anything else it's just
like this is who I am
take it or leave it one I think that's
very freeing for a lot of people but
also to is the type of people who at
least who I personally want to spend
time with there's a huge amount of
respect that comes with that right they
really kind of value other people that
have the ability to think kind of
independently who are comfortable in
their own skin all of those types of
attributes and so like to me it's if we
could get more people at least trending
in that direction
we actually would be a much more
resilient kind of respectful society to
some degree instead what I think ends up
happening is people you know you see it
at a party right some kind of social
event people show up and it's like I've
got this person who's a managing
director our next company who's now
talking to associate at Y company and
immediately there's some hierarchical
you know kind of understanding among two
humans that to me is just kind of I
don't know it's just a false god that
everyone's kind of listening to to some
degree so I think that's like the most
powerful position to be in is just to be
able to when you close your eyes and say
you know I am whatever it's just your
name that's it and it's just PI and me
that's very interesting and I will
inquire about that too much other than
to now ask you how would you like others
to see because there has to be some type
of attributes I mean I don't expect
anybody to too-short how my identity as
perhaps I don't expect them to as a
particularly I just I don't know
whatever I mean everyone's bad you know
I don't think I you know but how do you
want others to I just what it's good use
an identity do you want others because
certainly if you know I can't just think
of you as that I'm gonna give like mine
like maybe that I assigned to you is
kind of I remember saying this all off
you
very good and if you're a very good
listener so I would say one of the
things I would say is he's a good list
the other thing I would say is absence
of Aires
I don't feel like within our
conversation within the other podcast
you've tried to convey kind of something
that's all that competes with anybody
else I noticed that with him Harrington
so I would say I would I would say that
I would say that you know he's a good
listener and that he has that kind of
image mine's much simpler ready it's
just happy to me it's it's that simple
if the day I die everyone goes man that
dude really enjoyed life he was happy I
win right you want others so now when
you're thinking of your own identity now
you're not just looking the middle name
but you're also giving out some
attributes right like you're carrying
that with you you've got some awareness
that you're happy right so it's not a
self affirmation I don't know that you
are awesome but so you're thinking my
name and then happy well kids because
here's why right is when you go through
this exercise I would I'm kinda thinking
this off top of my head but I would put
people in two buckets either they want
people to think of descriptions of
themselves that end up being very cus of
grand icing right of like you know I am
important I am smart I am you know
whatever you want to put in that bucket
the reason why I immediately gravitate
to the word happy is because to me if
you and I hang out and you walk away
always saying that guys happy you
actually in some way get value out of
that right because you're much more
likely to struggle to be sad depressed
angry mad you know all of these negative
connotation states if you're hanging out
with people who are happy right and so
it's kind of one of these things where
ultimately all I can control us
myself and if I'm personally happy than
like that's all I care about
but by the way by being in that state
you hanging out with me talking to me
whatever it's more likely that you're
going to you know be happy be content be
these other things that are positive
rather than go into the negative I ask
you question two points be okay because
I'm so interested yeah very remarkable
mark and having you know as we've
watched Charlie loaders there's been
feeling nothing to fill that void and
now we're finally beginning to see some
people who can have a long form that can
be super smart a Charlie Rose month I
used to see them every day for breakfast
if you see in my restaurant super smart
but never smarter than its guests so I
think that's always really really
interesting so actually I'm not gonna
ask you David
so so instead of ask you to point to I
just want to understand that when you're
doing all these videos and you've had
some remarkable I mean truly remarkable
even the Bears yet financial barely
completely disagree with and the
pandemic people I definitely disagree
but a really remarkable interview very
humble and that has to be a hobby for
you all so it can't just be you know and
you do your letter which I read all the
time you so um clearly you're happy but
that has to be some part of your
identity so how does that how is that
fused into how you think of yourself
because that's so much after that it's
got to be stopped part and how do you
want others to perceive did you want me
to think of you as a happy person but
also remarkable worker who also has a
tremendous amount of this questioner
yeah and the happiness yeah I think it's
um it all is intertwined right it's hard
to segment each thing and it you know
I've said it before that the interviews
is probably the most selfish thing I do
and the reason why I say that is I get
to talk to super interesting people that
I I am the arbiter of who gets to come
on right I'm the final selection
committee right okay I want to talk to
this person I don't yeah so like that in
itself is some filtering mechanism of
like I'm willing to invest my time to
talk to this person and then during that
conversation I get asked the questions
that I want the answers to
so it's the ultimate learning experience
for me and I think that people are they
sitting there like oh my god like I get
a listen to this is so awesome thank you
so much for doing this whatever and I
was kinda like chuckle to myself right
I'm like are you kidding me like this is
such a benefit to me because many of
these people I would doubt that they
would talk to me if it wasn't going to
be recorded right or they wouldn't at
least go into such depth and spend so
much time and so it's almost as if the
audience is a tool in some case for me
to be able to learn and start as watch I
was feeling like no no you you're
mistaken here like the power dynamic is
like I should be thanking you for
listening because you're the reason why
I get to talk to these people okay so
here's a question 1.3 okay I apologize
for interrupting it good so I've been
really interested in your own identity
and I don't I'm asking the questions
because it's also a child it's a human
challenge wait I mean it's something we
all love the flu I mean and if we don't
go through it's probably the tragedy of
having lived a life without that type of
the learnings um so I just want to
understand your own identity you say
your name which is remarkable and now
the things saying your name and not
positive affirmation is um happy wait so
you you're happy yours your hard work
right this is all discretion yeah I mean
it's discretionary yeah is that fair to
say there's this questionnaire yes that
I think so okay so happy hard burger
discretionary effort all by himself
oh and intellectually inquisitive of
course I I think that that's
I don't know I find people who aren't
intellectually curious about things kind
of boring right I mean personally and
sure there's people who are happy not
being intellectually curious but I think
that's just my general nature and so I
found a way to uh to kind of get to do
that every day which you know frankly is
like it's like a cheat code for life in
some ways and I suppose you would want
and there's it's not even a question now
but I would suppose maybe it's more but
I would suppose or two I would suppose
that's also how you want other people I
mean if you to perceive you right as you
know you're happy but you clearly like
so then hard look if anybody sees your
body at work you're gonna say this is a
guy that's got a lot of discretionary
effort he could push a hot-dog card and
in 20 years he'd have 20 of them being
pushed on so it's just reality
great is this kind of intellectual
curiosity so because you do so much of
this do you feel that you want other
people to say this is who he is this is
his identity I think that's part of the
magic is like because I'm comfortable
whether people see the intellectual
curiosity the happiness all that stuff
or not kind of one of these things where
as I've gotten I think I've been able to
shed any identity outside of just my
name you then realised that all of those
other adjectives look I'm human right
when people say nice things about you
you're like oh that's great that they
think that about me even if you
sometimes question it yourself but at
the end of the day it just doesn't
bother me either way right and I think
that's also part of look one of the
positive parts of social media that
doesn't get credit because everyone
always looks through the negative
perspective is all the the vitriol all
the negative comments and just the that
the deep dark nasty part of social media
for people that have the large
followings that are very public and
things like that actually they've
developed incredibly thick skin
right like you you'd be hard-pressed to
say something that would you know really
kind of hurt me I've read it all I've
seen it all I've heard it all and most
people if they've kind of gone through
that gauntlet of public kind of openness
and vulnerability on the social
platforms I then it can almost backs
into this question of like at some point
yours like I literally don't care right
and I don't know if that's healthy or
not good or bad but like when you're at
that position it's just there's this
element of like it's very freeing right
and I don't know it makes me point 52.5
go ahead good I'm intellectually
inquisitive also and I know you own and
part of my identity is that I Drive
people crazy because I'm so
intellectually inquisitive and
unfortunately I don't have that stain
can tell it that same social
intelligence that you have so mine can
be not upsetting to people because you
know it's obviously the inhumanity and
sharing humanity but my phraseology is
can sometimes and the way I express it
can sometimes be a little bit you know
agitating my what upset yeah I mean
everybody you know can come off so
actually I won't ask I've asked you
enough I mean come on you're you're here
you might as well ask well I don't want
to interrogate too much but Mike my
question was though it's 2.5 which is
probably 2.9 is how do you observe you
know a person can't carry
so if awareness a person is gonna
deviate from you know what they would
like to be I call it but I'm sure you've
got a your own type of language but how
do you observe that in real calling and
how do you correct it how do you remedy
in so both it being happy because it
shows final might others but it being
happy because that takes effort right
and and how you view yourself and then
it making sure that when you're there
you expressing that happiness so there's
a part of your so how do you observe and
yourself how you can
that awareness that you've now shared
with me so you could also correct it
yeah but it's not there so I think that
this is probably the only way I know cuz
this is my personal experience and the
people that I've spent a lot of time
with have all gotten to the same point
through a similar path which is exposure
to the extremes right and what I mean by
that is so take my life for example one
of the best probably the number one best
experience I ever had in my life was
going to war because what it did is when
I came back it was very cut and dry on
an extreme level of is this thing going
to potentially lead to death or is it
not and that is such an extreme kind of
measurement framework right because most
people you know they worry more about is
this something that makes me upset or
not is this something that you know
makes me happy or not is this something
that's gonna bother me a day from now or
just right now like that like those are
the measurement tools they use when you
then extend your measurement tool out to
the absolute extreme of the spectrum you
say am I gonna die from this or not all
of a sudden there's a big big gap
between the answers yes and everything
else and so therefore you kind of get
re-centered very quickly on it's not
gonna kill me like I don't need to worry
about it right and your life almost
becomes simpler and easier because you
realize that that extreme worry or that
line almost that's where what I think a
normal person who hasn't been exposed to
those extreme situations like they worry
about that stuff way earlier in the
lifecycle of or the spectrum of kind of
where things fall for me I mean I've
literally been with friends and
something happens and they could you
know literally living they're about to
jump off a cliff or I mean they're just
worked up to the absolute extreme and
I'm sitting there and I couldn't care
less right because I just hey let's just
calm down and and move on right you're
not gonna remember this in 24 hours let
alone you know be worried about it I
don't think you can have that
self-awareness by reading a book I don't
think you can do it by
you know sitting and thinking about it I
literally think you've got to be put in
situations and so you know you you uh we
talk about it but obviously I've done a
lot of kind of extreme sports and
athleticism type of events and same
thing they're like you can read all the
books you want about you want to go run
the marathon or a hundred mile race or
whatever at some point you just got to
go do the extreme [ __ ] in order to be
physically prepared I think mentally is
the same thing right you gotta be
putting the extreme situations so that
you can almost condition your mind -
okay well I mean I can handle this thing
that's so far out there everything else
is you know it's it's a cakewalk so I
think that's probably the number one
thing that that helped me personally I
just don't know how and people have
asked me before I don't know how to
recreate that right how do you take an
average person who's not in the military
who's never gonna go face war and
recreate the mental conditions that
almost like hardened them I think you
see some of these guys like the David
Goggins of the world and these Navy
SEALs and stuff who are saying hey you
know go do one hard thing every day and
those that type of perspective yeah it
chips away at it and kind of put you in
the right direction something different
about it you know bomb going off right
then hey I went and I did a hundred
burpees today like it's just a little
bit I think of a watered-down version
but at least is a better step in the
right direction than something else
hopefully well I go ahead go ahead
frequently do you feel you're able to
practice as part of your daily life or
weekly life you know I I have my own
things and I really appreciated yours um
you know I I have things that I have
found are helpful for you know kind of
restoring myself a little bit and we're
still in it and I try and do it if we
can if I can form a notation for that
how do you practice this daily so in
some weird world I don't think that I
practice it in the sense of
I'm very bad about I don't meditate I
don't sit and kind of do a good daily
log like you do like like there's no
kind of one activity that I can point to
and say like that is part of this and
the only reason why I'm even aware of
this is over time enough people have
pointed it out to me where they've been
in the same situation as I have and they
say why did you not freak out or why did
you not worry and I did and so again
it's it's really weird in that um I
think there's two paths to get to the
same finish line one is you can have the
persistent daily or weekly type
check-ins that kind of keep you very
much calibrated down that path or you
can have one incredibly or a small
number of incredibly extreme experiences
and what ends up happening is the person
who gets calibrated let's say every day
right whether it's meditating writing or
whatever there's very little kind of
waning from that center line if you will
right that the variable is very small
because every day they get that the
recalibration the other person actually
has a lot more variation and in kind of
they're caught mental fortitude or you
know whatever it is but the thing is
that they already had such an extreme
experience that the error for margin is
so wide that even with all that
variation that they have it all falls
within the area of margin and therefore
kind of that they're able to keep going
in the right direction and so to me the
ultimate thing would be somebody who
early in their life can have their
really extreme experiences and also
incorporate the daily or more frequent
kind of calibrations and so it's like
from my stamp when I see people like
yourself who can sit and have those
daily calibrations like man I'm envious
of being able to do that because I just
don't do it right now I have the benefit
of falling back on these extreme
experiences and so I think they'll kind
of Holy Grail and all this is if you can
combine those two things you just can't
get shaken out of
this mental solitude if you will or kind
of state of happiness 2.9 alright let's
go
when was the last time you did an
extreme sport activity I don't know like
it depends on how you define extreme
obviously right you define I mean I
don't I'm not asking if you're Conor
McGregor or worried I would say the past
thing I did I ran the original marathon
with with my girlfriend at the time now
my fiancee number three who is that girl
plays so she knows me well enough to
know that the odds of me ever running a
marathon were close to zero unless if I
went and ran the original marathon every
time somebody my brothers or a friend
said oh I ran a marathon I would then be
able to say back to them yeah but you
didn't run the original just that alone
would get me to go do the original and
so I flew on a red-eye flight from
Seattle Washington to Greece and then
ran it you know a couple hours after
landing and there's one of these things
we're like I don't care how athletic you
are just it sucks you're running 26 you
know plus miles and then when you get
done you're like man that was awesome
right like I actually felt kind of
relieved and the endorphins and all that
stuff but you're like I'm good I don't
need to go do one of these tomorrow
right and so I think stuff like that
maybe that's kind of a calibration but
those are super infrequent at least for
one so question three all right
but what who is that woman that joins
you on those shorter I think their daily
has they yeah is on your fiance yeah yes
she um
she is somebody who if I had to kind of
put it into a framework she had her own
like extreme experience is very
different but but I think there's
correlations in terms of
every immigrant literally gets uprooted
from their home country they moved to
the United States I learn a new language
they got it you know go to all Bulgaria
ah that's awesome my daughter-in-law is
from Moldova okay yeah yeah so it's so
like you just get this this new
experience in life right and it doesn't
have to be the Eamonn from another
country you could also kind of move
around a lot as a kid or whatever but
like those types of extreme experiences
put you in a position I think where you
just have a kind of built in the best
way I've personally describe it is like
mental toughness is a muscle if you
don't exercise the muscle it big it
likes it comes to hypertrophy right and
that's essentially what ends up
happening so I don't know okay so three
point one all right and this is the old
Jewish behind me right is art are you
guys gonna have children and if so when
and if when how many all great questions
I have no clue I think that we would
like to have children at some point in
the future but no no immediate plans
does she agree with that yes it's I
think it's a thing where it's like
that's one of the things if you're gonna
get married you will you project out
that conversation before you get married
rather than then wait till later right
how long have you known her for almost
four years
oh and when did you guys get engaged
last year and did you know Amelia pond
meeting or well first did you come off
of a long relationship before or what
was your experience and no I knew I knew
the day I met her but literally set it
to her I think within the first 24 hours
who's she in agreement I took a look by
a little bit more convincing than than
me thank you for allowing me to do my
thing yeah of course I appreciate you
taking the time to do this where where
can people find you on the Internet
where
where can we send I linger every I'm
certainly on Twitter and I'm I try and
bring favor which I did like a week I
was really good but then I felt that I
was losing so much information flow from
Kovac because the only quality
information that's still kind of
circulating and available it happened on
Twitter Facebook is become garbage
I think Tsarevich was observed recently
observe that Twitter is the most freest
of the social media platforms and the P
says it you don't take it to the bag and
I hope you know there is a lot of good
information flowing so I went back both
them persuading people by bowing right
because that wine the market was down
and I really wanted people to you know
benefit I hate it's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity and you know balling was at
a hundred thirty no DMing people and I
was like if you have kids you know on
Facebook if you unlock you often um but
it's such good quality information I
mean there's so many doctors on in so
many professions and so many people
sharings but something that they've
found in like this off type of place and
a lot of them are specialists that are
able to give in not just the treatment
link it's a type of off perspective and
that's really helpful to me in my log I
love it yeah yeah that's it thank you so
much for your time for allowing me to
you know I can I could talk to you all
day long we will we would definitely
link to your Twitter I highly suggest
people go follow you on twitter to I can
piss a lot of people off alright Adam
thank you so much thank you so much for
your time